[Music]
on this Wednesday night pumping the
brakes on vehicle
theft the surge in crimes and what a
national Summit hopes to solve we have
become known globally as a donor Nation
for stolen
vehicles sentenced for leaking Secrets
how many years a former top RCMP
official will spend in jail fighting for
transgender
rights students walk out to protest
Alberta's new gender identity
rules and striking a cord at the Grammys
I was astonished how a guitar made by a
Calgary woman ended up in the hands of
Tracy
[Music]
Chapman global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin tonight with what's
being called a crisis in this country an
alarming rise in auto theft it is
skyrocketing in Canada so much so we're
becoming known around the world as an
easy Mark the problem is most acute in
Eastern Canada auto theft in Quebec was
up 50% in 2022 compared to the year
before in Ontario is up over 48% and
it's on the rise everywhere else too it
is highly lucrative and the stolen
vehicles are often quickly shipped
overseas today on the eve of a summit on
auto theft the public safety Minister
promised help to detect and search
shipping containers Abigail Beeman has
our top story tonight
it looks like they were in and out
within 10 minutes it's a nightmare
familiar to too many Canadians Kevin
McDonald's SUV was stolen from his
driveway in the middle of the night it
took about $2,000 and months to get it
back making him one of the lucky ones he
works in the Auto industry and has
plenty of ideas to share when he attends
the National car theft Summit hosted by
the federal government in Ottawa
Thursday obvious Solutions I mean
improving uh you know the amount of
employees that cbsa have as looking at
reciprocal agreements with various
policing agencies better collaboration
tops the list for many advocacy groups
as stories pile up of people with
trackers finding their stolen cars but
unable to get them back due to
jurisdiction issues as well as a call
for stricter reporting rules for cars
leaving the country there's no Silver
Bullet there's multiple things that have
to happen collectively and uh I think
that's where we'll see uh the biggest
impact is everybody coming together and
uh
taking action eager to show their taking
action late Wednesday ahead of the
summit the Federal Government tried to
address these concerns by announcing $28
million for the cbsa to find and search
containers with stolen vehicles the
agency will explore new detection
Technology Solutions and the use of
Advanced Analytical tools such as
artificial intelligence that
announcement overlaps with what the
opposition has been calling for for days
secure our
ports and lock up the car thieves
Thursday brings together different
levels of government Auto and insurance
stakeholders and police we have become
known globally as a donor Nation for
stolen vehicles with so much of the
problem linked to organized crime High
reward low risk it funds the guns and
the gangs and the and the drugs that are
coming into the country and it's a it's
a crime of opportunity and it's it's it
allows them to make you know some
serious money very quickly and with very
little recourse the Liberals are
promising more news to come from
Thursday's Summit both around technology
to make cars harder to steal and around
better resources for Canadian police to
work with interpole with so many of
these stolen cars ending up overseas
Abigail bman Global News Ottawa a former
highlevel RCMP intelligence official
found guilty of leaking top secret
information to police targets has been
sentenced to 14 years in prison an
Ontario Superior Court Judge today said
the actions of Cameron Oris not only
undermine Canada's reputation they
potentially put lives at risk ordis was
arrested in 2019 and with credit for
time served he will spend another seven
years in jail duia isri reports on the
sentencing and the
reaction Cameron ordis knew the
consequences of telling Canada's secrets
that's what the judge said in his
sentencing and ordis will pay for those
consequences 7 years in jail thought
this conduct was deserving of a sentence
that far exceeded the sentence imposed
by the trial judge the crown wanted 28
years minus time served Mr Cameron Oris
betrayed the
RCMP he betrayed our domestic
intelligence Partners Mr Cameron ortis
effectively compromised the trust that
Canada has burned Justice Robert marage
also called it a betrayal but thought 28
years was was too harsh despite agreeing
ordis violated his position of extreme
trust and that his actions potentially
put lives at risk ortis was arrested in
2019 for trying to sell classified
information to a cyber criminal and
suspected money launderers at the time
he was one of the highest ranking
civilian members of the RCMP he had
access to some fairly highly classified
technical information on Communications
and Communications intercepts so did he
do damage yes sure he did the judge
called Oris somewhat of an enigma
Witnesses described his work ethic and
intelligence Michael kovrig one of the
two Michaels jailed in China was a
friend and sent a letter of support to
the judge the defense had argued for no
jail time and now plans to appeal
obviously disappointed uh we were hoping
to have a significantly lower sentence
but I understand where Justin M came
from he was given a difficult task to
choose between two very different
extremes while while the trial is now
over the judge says Canada's reputation
may never recover saying that oris's
actions undermine Canada's credibility
among its five eyes intelligence sharing
Partners since ortis had access to their
secrets as well tiia isri Global News
Ottawa there is an update on a special
police task force investigating a wave
of extortion attempts targeting the
South Asian community in Peele region
west of Toronto police revealed 24
charges have been laid in relation to 29
extortion attempts dating back to
November of 2023 a variety of businesses
including restaurants bakeries and
jewelry stores were targeted all with
South Asian owners nine of the incidents
have involved shootings with multiple
rounds being fired there are similar
trends that we've been seeing uh in
Alberta and as well as Lower Mainland
British Columbia as well as in certain
locations in the US PE police say they
are working with investigators in those
provinces five suspects have been
arrested in connection with three
alleged incidents across the greater
Toronto area since the task force was
set up in December while there have no
been no reported injuries PE police say
South Asian business owners are being
threatened with violence unless they
hand over cash or money transfers
Toronto police have identified a third
suspect in the shooting death of an
innocent bystander last July 19-year-old
Ahmed Ali is now wanted for manslaughter
and robbery with a firearm there was a
physical altercation between three males
that we believe was a robbery and it
escalated into violence when two men
brandished hand guns and exchange
gunfire 44-year-old karolina hubner
Marat was walking in Toronto's
Leslieville neighborhood when a bullet
hit her homicide detectives believe Ali
fled to Somalia shortly after the
shooting a Canada wide warrant is out
for his arrest and interpole is involved
Canada does not have an extradition
treaty with Somalia three other people
are also facing charges in that case the
RCMP says a Montreal man has been
charged with threatening to kill prime
minister Justin Trudeau 30-year-old Paul
claro appeared in court today RCMP say
the threats were made on social media on
the social media platform X and
investigated by the Force's National
Security enforcement team the force says
it's not the first time they've
investigated threats against Trudeau and
that the threats have increased since
the pandemic the federal opposition
leader Pierre PV has weighed into
Alberta's controversial planned rule
changes for transgender youth when asked
today if he's against the use of puberty
blockers for people under the age of 18
he said yes I think that we should
protect children and their ability to
make adult decisions when they are
adults the fact that Premier Smith and
uh Pierre POV want government to take
away the option for parents and their
vulnerable youth you in consultation
with their doctors to make the right
decisions for them is anchored in
ideology and is not about protecting the
most
vulnerable in Alberta backlash against
Premier Danielle Smith's plan gender
policies is growing today hundreds of
students across the province walked out
of class in protest hether uck West
reports on the polarizing policy
[Applause]
proposal at 10:00 a.m. high school
students across Alberta joined the
chorus of those opposed to a suite of
policies proposed by the Alberta
Government restricting transgender
rights I know trans kids like little
kids and I want to make sure that
they're growing up into a world that's
safe and that accepts them the premier
of Alberta has said that the policies
restricting access to puberty blocking
therapy for those under 16 and to gender
affirming surgery for those under 18 are
designed to protect children from making
decisions they would later regret citing
the experience of Lois Cardinal a first
nation's woman who underwent bottom
surgery at the age of 21 I remember
waking up in the surgical Suite saying
what have I done while medical
professionals the Alberta Teachers
Association and transgender support
organizations were not consulted in
drafting Alberta's policy Cardinal who
on her social media accounts frequently
refers to transgenderism as a mental
disorder was consulted by the United
conservative party I support it and then
there's others within the community that
don't and I understand that but this is
the first step but this transgender man
whose identity we've agreed to protect
over safety concerns disagrees he
received Top surgery at the age of 15 a
procedure he believes saved his life if
these policies were enacted like 7 years
ago I wouldn't have been able to do any
of the things that I did um and I yeah I
don't think I think that I probably
would have commit suicide had it not had
it happened then well each point of view
represents an individual lived
experience medical evidence indicates
cases involving regret are exceedingly
rare studies show it to be between 1 and
2% and that the benefits to the mental
health of transgender youth outweigh the
risk it creates a false debate so when
you sort of call into question the
medical evidence and say actually like
you shouldn't be receiving care like
there isn't agreement on this and in
terms of the puberty suppression and you
know that intervention like we have a
lot of consensus actually it's not it's
not a
debate which is why those opposed to the
policies say they'll keep fighting to
protect transgender rights Heather urix
West Global News
Calgary Israel has flat out rejected a
proposed ceasefire and its war on Gaza
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu is
saying there is no solution but a
complete and total Victory the war now
into its fourth month will continue and
Israeli forces will push further into
Southern Gaza it's not the result the US
Secretary of State wanted he is back in
Israel trying to find a way to end the
Bloodshed the US provides Israel with
tens of billions of dollars in economic
and military aid but as Crystal ganing
Reports American influence over what
happens next seems
limited operational success is what
Israel prime minister is focused on not
peace Benjamin Netanyahu says the war on
Hamas and Gaza could last months longer
but that Victory is Within
Reach I would like to emphasize again
that there is no solution other than
total Victory if Hamas survives in Gaza
it is only a matter of time until the
next Massacre a definitive rejection by
Netanyahu to a Hamas counterproposal to
pause fighting a proposal that had the
US Secretary of State once again
crisscrossing the Middle East meeting
with key players while there are some
clear non-starters in hamas's response
uh we do think it creates space for
agreement to be reached the Hamas
proposal had laid out three phases with
fighting paused for 45 days at each
stage Israeli women males under 19 and
sick and elderly hostages would be
released in Phase One in ex exchange for
the release of Palestinian women and
children held in Israeli jails and the
withdrawal of Israeli soldiers from
populated areas in
Gaza families of Israelis taken hostage
on October 7th have been fighting to
keep their loved ones fate front and
center my mom was released without a
deal she was released because of
humanitarian reasons and there is
nothing stopping Hamas from releasing
more people her father she says is frail
and has spent four months in captivity
in Gaza I hope that he has the strength
it's very hard to survive something when
you are frail some Israelis have
expressed fear that the fighting means
there will be no hostages Left Alive
Netanyahu says IDF operations will move
South into Rafa with the aim of
demilitarizing Gaza Rafa is where more
than 1 million displaced Gins are taking
Refuge Crystal ganing Global News London
still digging out from a mammoth
snowstorm coming up the pleas for more
plows as patience in Cape Bretton runs
thin Coast Guard officer Cadets are
being called in to help people in Cape
Breton dig out from a record snowfall
over the weekend many people are still
trapped in their homes the provincial
and federal governments are promising
help but as Heidi pachic reports it's
not happening fast
enough about a 100 officer Cadets from
the Canadian Coast Guard college in
Sydney hit the snowy streets to dig
residents out after they dug their own
way off campus and if we had
difficulties getting out of our own
College imagine how much people are
having trouble getting their own homes
their efforts greeted with relief
because I know I can go to my medical
appointments and I can get out faster
many hand make lighter work but the job
is massive there are residents
throughout Cape Breton still blocked in
especially in rural areas we did not
have the equipment to deal with this so
fast so Furious snow completely blocks
the driveway at the home of Terry
matthys and paty Geisler their vehicles
buried they're on a list to be bulldozed
out from their Albert Bridge home
hopefully in the next 24 hours we have a
friend her her mother is is very ill
they have a really long driveway and
they're right in Sydney River and can't
get anybody to plow their so if
something happens to mom there's nothing
anybody can do we still have residents
that are not plowed out yet um there's
communities that are not plowed out yet
the province says 40 extra pieces of
equipment are now in Cape Breton but
Cape Breton Regional municipality
councel Gordon McDonald says they need
much more I don't know why um we don't
have the deserves in to at least look at
the situation um we have a very serious
um situation here the military would go
a long way as it did after post-tropical
storm Fiona but this time Ottawa hasn't
gone that far whatever the province has
requested from us we've been there but
the problem is you can't buy a
snowblower right now in Cape
Bron 4 days since the storm hit and
Counting there is so much digging left
to do and more anxious waiting for those
still stuck as time goes on Heidi pachic
Global News
hellofax ahead turmoil in Pakistan after
deadly bombings on the eve of an
[Music]
election Pakistan is on edge tonight
after two bombings near the offices of
candidates on the eve of that country's
general
election more than 26 people were killed
at least 50 others injured the blast
happened 150 km apart in the country's
Southwest the first rocked the election
campaign office of an independent
candidate less than an hour later there
was a blast at an election office for
the country's ultraconservative party
the so-called Islamic State group has
claimed responsibility for both bombings
Pakistan's election has been marred by
violence and claims of pole
rigging Russia launched a series of air
strikes across Ukraine early today
killing at least five civilians at least
three major cities were hit including
the capital keev and more than 40 people
were injured the European Union's top
Diplomat was in ke at the time
discussing military aid and financial
support for Ukraine more Western help is
needed by Ukraine which has shortages of
ammunition and personnel as the fight
against Russia approaches its second
anniversary some good news for a of
orcas that appeared to be trapped in
drift ice off Japan's northern Island
Japanese officials monitoring the killer
whales say they've managed to escape
Drone footage from Tuesday shows about a
dozen orcas clustered together in a
small opening in the ice poking their
heads up to breathe they were spotted by
a local fisherman about a kilometer off
Hokkaido and they're gone now it's
believed they made it out through gaps
in the
ice and this stunning photo of a young
polar bear sleeping on a floating chunk
of ice has won 2023 is wildlife
photographer of the Year People's Choice
Award it was taken off the coast of sard
Norway by an amateur photographer from
the UK organizers of the competition
call it breathtaking and poignant and
say it allows us to see the beauty and
fragility of our
planet hitting a high note next the
Calgary connection to Tracy Chapman's
Grammy
[Music]
performance millions of people were
captivated watching the Grammys on
Sunday especially the magical moment
moment when Tracy Chapman who hardly
ever performs anymore appeared on stage
playing her hit song fast car one woman
in Calgary couldn't quite believe her
eyes the acoustic guitar Chapman was
playing was the one that Calgary woman
had made by hand years ago Carolyn Curry
de Castillo has the story of how it got
there music has always been a passion
for Judy threat but it wasn't until the
former philosophy Professor started
making instruments that her Talent hit a
high note a friend of mine that I was in
a a folk Club House band with built a
archtop guitar for me so I started
hanging around at his at his Studio
while he was building it and I got I got
hit uh I got the bug for
building soon after she quit academics
and switched careers I went into the
department office and rescinded my
application for the next year and said
no I think I'm going to take some time
off and build some guitars in 1999 she
crafted a guitar and tried to sell it in
Calgary with no luck she ended up
shipping it to a music store in paloalto
California it was there that a certain
folk musician by the name of Tracy
Chapman walked into the store looking
for a smaller guitar and he just reached
over and handed her that one and she
eventually left the store with it that
was in 2001 over the past 20 years Tracy
Chapman wasn't a household name
anymore but her song fast car was on the
charts again when covered by country
artist Luke Colmes on Sunday they
performed the song together at the
Grammys in Los Angeles meanwhile back in
Calgary the retired guitar maker gets an
email from a friend saying he spotted
Judy's guitar Tracy Chapman strumming it
on stage for the world to see I was
astonished and I've seen pictures every
once in a while of her playing it um but
you know sort of dropped out of
Performing and so I didn't know if she
still had it I mean I'm hoping that
she's hung on to it because it's sort of
become a trusted
friend and and if that's the case then
then that's wonderful cuz that's that's
sort of what everybody hopes for when
they're when they're building
guitars Carolyn Curry detillo Global
News what a story that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
freezen tonight's your Canada is this
seagull in Picton on onario we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at global.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye